isabelle marjorie tremblay adore voyager
et a toujours consacré une partie de son
budget pour parcourir le monde
mais pour un deuxième été consécutif
elle et sa famille resteront au québec
pour les vacances elle a fait une croix
sur un projet au mexique
dre que j'ai vraiment - vous prendre
l'avion premièrement bien sûr payer
trois jours à l'hôtel ça coûterait une
fortune
puis je suis dans un état d'acceptation
de la situation je me dis je reste si
c'est l'occasion de découvrir une
nouvelle chose nous l'avions déjà
rencontré en mai dernier pour la
questionner sur ses vacances je peux pas
imaginer à être ni à la maison ni même à
montréal pendant tout l'été
après un an de pandémie et malgré la
troisième vague et les dit elle dans un
bien meilleur état d'esprit en vue de
l'été on a réservé des terrains de
camping pour deux fins de semaine on a
réservé une semaine au chalet à
charlevoix et puis on devra analyser la
madeleine pour une semaine aussi donc on
redoute elle a bien fait de réserver d'
avance encore cet été
les chalets et les campings seront pris
d'assaut à travers la province
dans les parcs nationaux du québec la
sépaq par deux tours de réservation
jamais vu auparavant pour un début avril
une étude de la chaire démontre hic 80%
des gens qui avaient voyagé au québec
l'année dernière
voulant connaître plus du québec et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour toutes les
régions et est d'ailleurs partout on se
prépare pour le faire de manière
convenable réussi le québec est vraiment
gagnant cet été chantale lapointe dirige
la section voyages de ses à québec
depuis la réouverture de ces quatorze
agences en février les réservations pour
l'été au fait un bond de 234% alors que
l'an dernier c'était presque mort
cette année les à la madeleine est un
des grands gars
entre la gaspésie et la côte-nord est en
progression importante des produits
superbes qui gagne à être découvert les
agences de voyages certifiés comme le ca
propose des forfaits subventionné qu'on
retrouve sur le site explore quebec.com
le ministère du tourisme est 25% des
forfaits qui sont annoncés pour inciter
la population à découvrir le québec
les modèles prédictifs avec lesquels on
travaille aussi à 25 à 35 %
d'augmentation des recettes touristiques
par rapport à l'an dernier par rapport à
l'an dernier
alors c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle qu'on choisisse un forfait ou
qu'on organise son propre voyage
le mot d'ordre reste le même réservé
tant son hébergement que ses activités
entreprise s'appelle rhodia légal
liberté sauf que dans ce cas si cette
année on doit me plaît du film liberté
celle agence authentique canada les
employés sont en télétravail et les
affaires tournent au ralenti faute de
clientèle internationale
mais l'intérêt des québécois pour la
location d'un véhicule récréatif permet
à lagence d'éviter une saison
catastrophique
la semaine dernière il ya eu 40 v axes
sont réservés mais ça commence à être un
réel problème parce que y'a plus de
disponibilité la sauce est certain
blue est inverse peut coûter 250 à 300
dollars par jour en plus du camping jean
leloup évoque lui aussi l'est du québec
comme destination numéro un
mais cet été beaucoup de québécois
veulent aller plus loin l'engouement
qu'on a plus cette année qui était pas
loin derrière c'est véritablement
l'ouest canadien à raison de 50 %
environ des demandes faute d'aller à
l'étranger
l'attrait des rocheuses et de la côte
ouest et donc plus fort sur le site
expedia calgary vancouver figurait
d'ailleurs en tête des destinations les
plus recherchées par les québécois en
janvier à banff on les espère en grand
nombre
l'ontario attirera aussi bon nombre de
québécois plus que les maritimes
même si la bulle atlantique devait
éclater et les gens sont sandby
seine-maritime
ils ont été chaudes et l'année passée
avec ce qui s'est passé ça parait il y
encore des questions
à la vitesse où se déroule la
vaccination aux états unis les
frontières pourrait-elle rouvrir pour
l'été et surtout quel sera l'impact de
la troisième vague sur les déplacements
dans trois mois
sereine isabelle margerie a simplement
hâte à juillet au passé vraiment du bon
temps on a des parades au québec on a
des immenses terres et on a plein de
choses à faire alors c'est pas comme un
prix de consolation c'est juste pas
laissé l'occasion de voyager chine
l'international attendra pour un
deuxième été de suite les québécois
découvriront leur québec
[Musique]